russian president vladimir putin says
that he will allow inspectors to visit
the japan nuclear power plant in a call
with france's president emmanuel macron
the russian leader said officials from
the international atomic energy agency
will be allowed to assess the situation
on the ground russian troops are
stationed at the plant which is 40
kilometers from zaparisia in ukraine's
east both moscow and kiev has have
accused each other of firing near the
facility which is the largest of its
kind in europe
nearby residents are increasingly
concerned about a possible disaster and
are preparing for the worst
and for more we can bring in dw
correspondent jan philip schultz who
joins us from odessa vladimir putin says
the un will be granted permission to
inspect the nuclear complex can you tell
us will this help ease what's obviously
been an incredibly tense situation there
well at least it's some good news after
weeks of horrible news surrounding the
nuclear power plant and
sapodicia
we don't know yet
if it will really take place there have
been many announcements from the russian
side in the past that were misleading
but it's remarkable because putin
actually seems to agree to the
conditions on the ukrainian side and let
the international inspectors travel
through ukrainian controlled territory
but the situation around the nuclear
power plant is still very dangerous of
course
we we're getting reports about new
shelling but it's not only the shelling
of the site but it's also growing
concerns regarding possible power
outages and outages of
the cooling systems there that could
lead to a potential disaster
the ukrainian president of vladimir
zelinski has welcomed the idea of this
inspection but you know as you are
saying there's no clear time of when
when it will actually happen can you
give us a sense of how people in the
region are feeling about the idea of the
inspection and what's been going on
well some russian authorities said that
it could actually happen as early as the
beginning of september but
as we said before it's it's nothing is
for sure yet of course the ukrainians
highly welcome this
initiative
they would be very happy about these
inspectors on the ground but of course
they know that they also can't perform
any miracles and they can't prevent a
possible nuclear disaster all alone we
have to keep in mind that there is
shelling in the region still on a daily
basis so it's good news it's a step
forward but it's definitely not a
breakthrough
we are also hearing reports of potential
ukrainian drone attacks on uh
territories occupied by russia what more
can you tell us about those
yeah there are
reports about new drone attacks that
have taken place in the past hours
they come just one day after reports of
explosions in occupied territory and
even
in russia
itself
officials here in ukraine don't
officially comment on these incidents
but there are some senior officials that
have hinted that
ukraine could be behind these attacks so
it obviously shows ukraine's growing
abilities to to hit
russia even far away from the front
lines and to attack
important supply lines yeah and philip
thanks so much that's jan philip schultz
reporting from odessa